[Music]
hello everybody happy friday i thought
that today i'd film a day in the life
vlog i guess it's been a while since i
vlogged just for one day
and i thought why not i just finished my
meeting for the day i only had one so
the rest of the day i'm just doing kind
of writing planning
actually no editing but i am putting out
a video so
in the life of a content creator
software engineer turned content creator
girl
in san diego living her life yeah it's a
10 10 right now so i'm just gonna
keep doing some more work
and maybe go to a coffee shop or
something later
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we're just at a gas station
right now i'm getting gas but we're
gonna go
uh gas get bagels
that was very close amazon truck man
and then we're gonna go to
the cafe and work for a little bit this
cafe closes pretty early though so i'm
only gonna be there for a little bit i
usually go to this cafe at least once a
week to write in the mornings because
they've got awesome coffee
good vibe
but i haven't gone this week so i need
to make my quota so we're gonna do that
check out my fit isn't it cute yellow
blue
yellow socks white shoes i mean
even my brother complimented me on my
fit today
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm so dehydrated but
once you get lunch cafe went to the
beach for a little quick
beach time now we're home yeah it's kind
of a chill friday i did all the things
that i absolutely needed to do and
anything else is uh i don't have to get
it done today but it'd be nice to get it
done today i'm gonna put away some
veggies from our csa box right now and
then maybe work for like another
30 45 minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
we are
going to korean food because scott's
been watching a lot of korean englishmen
and the youtube channel now we really
crave korean food so we're going to a
spot that we used to go to in college
all the time meeting up with someone
raised friends
that's what at least i hope they have
that because that's my favorite that's
literally the main reason why we're
going to this spot
[Music]
[Music]
all right everybody thank you so much
for watching i hope you liked the video
so that's a little bit of like what a
day in my life can look like it was kind
of a interesting
day of going to the cafe and going to
dinner and stuff like that but good
friday indeed i just want to take a
moment to say thank you to the sponsor
of today's video nordvpn so a vpn as we
all know is a great way to conceal your
identity and protect your privacy when
online specifically when you're going to
places like cafes and stuff like i did
and you're using their wi-fi then you're
always going to want to use a vpn to
make sure that you are safe it does
things like conceal your ip close your
virtual location seals your data traffic
from snoopers and protects you from
various cyber attacks and nor vpn let's
be real is a great tool to do that
nordvpn not only does all of that but it
also has an advanced threat protection
feature in order to make your internet
experience smoother and safer it helps
identify malware written files stops you
from landing on malicious websites and
blocks trackers and intrusive ads on the
spot once you enable the threat
protection feature in your newer vpn app
settings it'll protect your browsing
even when you're not connected to a vpn
server so in order to get this very
exclusive deal then go to nordvpn.com
mayuko to get a two-year plan plus one
month free for the cost of about a cup
of coffee and as always nordvpn always
provides a 30-day money-back guarantee
thank you again so much noor vpn for
sponsoring thank you for watching and
i'll see you next time bye
you